my name is terry i'm the vice chair  scott chief parliament and and while  it's great and that young people will  probably be allowed to vote in the  scottish parliamentary elections in  2016. a prime minister i'm just  wondering in order to not disenfranchise  young people from politics in general  and when will we be able to vote and  then the uk elections in the european  elections well the issue in the uk  elections is for the westminster  parliament to decide and i said uh  recently i thought it perhaps is attack  it's time that we had a a debate about  this  personally i have not yet been persuaded  that votes for 16 and 17 year olds is  the right approach i think that basing  more things around 18 being the age of  majority is the right answer but i'm a  open-minded kind of guy i listened to  arguments and very happy to listen to  the arguments and clearly it helped to  generate a lot of passion and interest  in the  scottish referendum